hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on foreigner again we have a
little bit of a different way of doing
this video we have the new midseason
patch notes that went live a couple
hours ago I would have had this video
probably a little bit earlier but I was
in the middle of making a video for a
completely different game that will be
going up probably later after this is
done but since this is the midseason
patch I don't want to cover this this is
going to be going live on September the
12th so we're gonna be getting a lot of
different buffs as you can see this is a
pretty big large chunk of patch notes
for a lot of the characters a lot of bug
fixes so we got tons of stuff to go over
so as long as like to be if you're doing
Joe subscribe if you're new and let's
get started so as I said this is going
to be going live on September the 12th
we have a lot of stuff to get through
first up we have general changes to
revenge a lot of adjustments and then
one bug fix one of them being the active
feats and debuffs are not working
properly when receiving revenge gains
receiving multiple attacks on the same
frame will grant the right amount of
revenge countering a guard break will
not grant revenge gain and captains and
Guardians are no longer allowed to count
as active opponent they will not give
any revenge game and in the bug fix is
that it fixed an issue on certain
attacks that were not provided revenge'
gain all attacks will not give the right
amount of revenge obviously we've had a
lot of problems with the game in the
past with revenge being weird being in
three V ones and getting revenge in two
seconds whereas sometimes people would
get it never and the bar would never go
up and then some people would get it for
a couple moves even if it's a one on one
so revenge was all sorts of [ __ ] up so
this is definitely going to change it as
will it change everything and will it
keep it locked in and actually be
correct who knows we'll have to see
tomorrow when the patch goes live or
zone attack we have I believe I counted
this beforehand 19 out of the 25
characters I think we have in this game
24 25 warden peacekeeper conqueror law
bringer Ken say Orochi no bushi Raider
Berserker Valkyrie shinobi are a
muchacha man Highlander gladiator
Shaolin T on DJJ and he Toki REE all got
removed brief one second stamina
regeneration pauses that occurred during
most his own attacks the developer
comment was the standardization of zone
attacks to have no head in stamina regen
so there's that for about every
character in the cast I think except 5
there's a few characters which
I'm not gonna name cuz it's not worth it
that haven't gotten this maybe because
they don't need it or they already have
that standardization but it seems like a
lot of the cast definitely didn't for
the fire it's an adjustment the time
between each damage tick and the
duration of the fire has been doubled
damage stays the same but it's done over
a longer period of time I think this is
completely fair fire did do a lot of
damage and it did a fuckload really
quickly so having it do it that same
amount for just a longer period I don't
really see that as a big issue so I'm
completely cool with that so a lot of
fire feeds fire flasks all that stuff
might be a little bit nerfed from this
but I still think they're gonna be very
powerful in the game
we have fighter updates first up is
peacekeeper and there's gonna be a lot
of numbers which is why I specifically
wanted to do it this way because me
shouting numbers like hit Recovery's 800
milliseconds now 900 it's gonna be a lot
of numbers and you won't be able to keep
track of it which is why I wanted to do
it like this so peacekeeper had an
adjustment for her and sangwich sallet
aureus horribly butchered name let
attacks are now enhanced against a
bleeding target adjustment is it reduced
all the heavy starter recoveries hit
recoveries now 800 instead in 900
milliseconds normal block is now 800 900
superior block is 900 out of 1000 miss
recovery is now 1,000 out of 11,000 so
all those recoveries are gonna be sped
up by 100 milliseconds and then also
adjusted the heavy finisher recoveries
as well for hit recovery 800 and 900
normal block 800 and 900 superior is 900
to 1000 and then miss recovery is now
800 as opposed to 1100 so just like the
one from before the heavy starters and
her heavy finishers are going to get 100
millisecond less time for recoveries
except the Miss which is gonna get a
giant one of 300 milliseconds if it's a
finisher cuz of course our heavy
finisher is a very long move so that's
pretty nice
and the fact that the light attacks are
now enhanced against a bleeding target
is pretty interesting I know they wanted
to make this with peacekeeper they
wanted to do this thing with pk so
that's because they didn't want to over
buffer the one didn't want to over nerve
her so she is still getting changes
every so often you're probably gonna be
seeing her a lot in the future patches
because they're gonna try to give her a
lot of changes but they're going a small
baby step at a time
not overstep and [ __ ] up the character
Valkyrie Connor got the same treatment
but I'm gonna read it again reduced all
light finisher recoveries her hit
recovery on light finishers is now 600
as opposed to 900 normal block is 600 as
opposed to 900 superior block is 700 and
not 800 and then the Miss recovery is
700 instead of 1100 so her recoveries
actually got a lot larger of a distance
as opposed to the 100 from PK these are
now 300 even 400 milliseconds faster
which is pretty interesting and then for
the read and the top heavy finishers the
hip recovery is 800 normal block is 700
superior block is 800 miss recovery is
800 as well so once again 3 to 400
millisecond changes so that might be big
for her and then for her all heavy
finishers which includes the sides of
course 800 as opposed to 9 700 as
opposed at 9 as well 8 instead of 10 and
then 8 instead of 11 so once again 100
to 300 millisecond changes so either way
good buffs all around some small stuff
but it might make a big deal in the main
game when it goes live and also she has
an adjustment that allows her top light
finisher to cause a light hit reaction
this originally was a heavy this might
mean that the heavy because heavies and
mediums allow the opponent's who I
believe get while supplied and alleged
so I think with this change coming for
light hit they it might not be legible
and it also might not be wall splatter
Bowl that might need a little bit more
testing because I don't really play
Valkyrie but if anyone wants to let me
know in the comments below for that I'd
be greatly appreciated for warlord his
they tighten the timing on dodging a
headbutt by 300 milliseconds and then
they reduced the recovery of his zone
from 600 and 1,000 which was pretty nice
conker got increased damage to his
infinite light chain from 218 from 13
which I'm not sure if that was a smart
idea but it'll be interesting to see and
they also sped up his light attack
starters and they're now 500 as opposed
to 600 but those are from the side not
the top so overall pretty nice damage
buff to conquer we'll have to see how
that plays out might be a little bit too
much damage but once again we'll have to
see
Nobu she got reduced recovery on her
regular light finishers the hit
recoveries you already get the deal
they're all gonna be faster any reduced
recovery of the zone attack faint by 100
milliseconds to prevent Garen
guard break after the first block of the
first hit which is pretty nice Shino
began adjustment after a charged heavy
attack after a chart you know we got a
bit of adjustment after a charge attack
is blocked from point blank the opponent
no longer no longer gives the opponent
it guaranteed guard break was so that's
interesting
usually I didn't really get a guard
break off that stuff I never really did
that stuff anyway more like did -
attacks or did heavies if I was close so
if you did do that it's not gonna happen
anymore but it's only at point-blank
range Highlander got the same trim as a
lot of people this is for his recoveries
on defensive form heavy finishers so
once again these are all gonna be sped
up faster some of these are actually 500
milliseconds as you could see the normal
block recovery 700 and then it was it
was 1200 so that's pretty quick they
reduced the stamina cost on his
offensive form enhanced lights from 16
era firms from 27 to 16 they reduced the
stamina cost of all of his full zone
attack from ninety a used used to be 90s
now 60 distributing as 40 with the first
hit and then ten and then ten so it's
pretty interesting they're still gonna
be losing a lot of stamina if you do
fainted so definitely be aware cuz that
forty is a giant chunk of stamina shaman
also got the same treatment with her
zone attack he used to be 70 and it's
now 60 so once again it's going to go
forty ten and then five and five so if
you do feint it midway through your ear
end up going to be losing 50 stamina as
opposed to 60 so that's pretty
interesting it's he only got another
adjustment remove the additional 20
stamina costs from canceling the side
dragon dodged into a Dodge itself and
adjusted I'll be right stand basic
attacks trajectories to be a lot more
horizontal I think we could skip the
part with the with this recovery but
it's for his heavy relentless change
finishers once again you can read these
if you want but these are more more or
less three - you know 200 300 or 400
milliseconds faster for all recoveries
which is nice they modified the damage
distribution of the death point strike
any death point strike alternative and
went to 777 as opposed to twelve six six
also if you can tell the old damage used
to add up to 24 as you can see here but
now it is 21 so instead like I said as
opposed to it being twelve from six to
six its I'm going to just be sevens
across the board so maybe maybe not
fainting the first two might be a smart
I don't think that's a smart idea
anymore but
I don't really see this is a big issue
shaolin's the light attacks are a bit
fast so I don't really have an issue
with this but Shaolin players you might
get you guys won't have a problem let me
know in the comments below
black prior got tightened timing with
his tenebris rising Yurman Gunder got
the improved tracking on these zealots
tried sprint attacks that's nice and
some map changes changing capture points
for AC making it probably bigger and you
know railings and blocking off stuff for
legend and stuff which is always nice
and then for customization they changed
the team color assigning of color
swatches that could be used for
confusing the team identification the
color swatches themselves were not ma
we're not modified only the team color
of signing so these are all of the
attacker ones right here this is a lot
of attacker colors and these are the
defender colors not as much but still a
huge amount we changed these colors to
neutral only because they could be
confusing for team identification color
swatches were not modified and then it's
these down here so a lot of them are
actually coming to neutral because of
the wrong identification and it might be
a bit of a problem what I'm ok with I'm
always okay with getting new neutral
color so let me know in the comments
below do you guys think I feel like
that's more customization and I'm down
for that
the rest of this stuff was mostly bug
fixes nothing incredibly crazy but of
course if you do want to see this
yourself I will leave it down in the
description down below if you want to
check out the bug fixes since we're
usually here for the adjustments of
course the bug fixes are important but
they're not incredibly as important as
you know some of the adjustments and the
recoveries but yeah that's what we got
for today's patch going live on
September the 12th and if you're
watching this on September the 12th it
should be live as you're watching this
video yeah guys hopefully you guys
enjoyed this little bit of a different
style it was a really long patch with a
lot of giant numbers so I just said [ __ ]
it let's record it this way and see how
it goes big guys like to VP do enjoy
subscriber free new I covered the
informational site a foreigner that mean
the balance changes the hero updates the
patch notes and the leaks if you want to
be kept up today with everything
happening than the world before honor I
never miss out and an update
definitely subscribe the channel
hopefully there'll be a news video
tomorrow which then if that's the case
I'll see you guys tomorrow but not I'll
probably see you guys next week cuz
we're going to be getting I believe the
new event on September the 19th which is
gonna be sick awesome so definitely let
me know what you guys think about that I
guess take care have girls today and
peace out
you